i'm looking in as an outside observer
i have a lot of contacts now because
i've made contacts with
other journalists most of the i think
i'm one of the only
from the cult people from the cultural
left who's out there
immersing himself in both sides of this
protest and going
going back and forth and and uh um
so i i keyed into that people were
asking me well who
who was who was it who was it sure that
front line
had to be paramilitary they had to be
versed in tactics
the fellow that we talked about who
defined himself as federalists but were
were you know saying that you know there
are some neo-nazi leanings there and and
uh uh he defines himself as an extremist
he said he studied tape he said you
don't know how many hours of
a video i've watched i studied antifa
and he calls them
antiphon and one thing you know when we
let we we spoke last time i parsed
what i say i call antifa aligned groups
that's the terminology i use because
there is no one
singular antifa and part of the belief
that there
is one singular antifa that has
communist leanings
that vacuum of information our inability
is the press
to say exactly what's been going on
since
june and define that has left it open
for conspiracy i would argue
and so these cultures of conspiracy are
filling in the blanks with their
own information and i held i held a very
interesting
and i got every all three of us got heat
on new year's eve i did a live stream
with a black lives matter organizer from
utah
and a proud boys uh um
or leader uh from chapter leader from
utah as well
who befriended each other over the
summer and
started debating each other and they
struck up this friendship and they
realized
that they were fighting about all this
other stuff but they had several
comment points of commonality of
interest when it came to police reform
prison reform getting big money out of
the elections
dealing with housing you know they
agreed on all of these fronts and yet
they were fighting
about political identification and they
they came
forward right after the president
mentioned the proud boys well actually
was joe biden that mentioned it in the
debate and
the president uh notoriously said stand
by
stand back and stand by and and
during that um they came out a couple
days later
and there they got very little coverage
i think b-e-t
and maybe uh one right-wing uh
publication
wrote something about it but it didn't
get much play that they
realized oh my gosh we have all these
points of commonality that we actually
agree on stuff
we did this live stream and even the the
proud boy was saying
i'm nervous because there are people
there are people who have military
experience
that are pissed off that are that are
that feel disenfranchised
and i said well what did we expect
in the sense that if you don't call it
if you're the media and you don't call
it objectively you don't tell it
like it is since june wouldn't we
think that other people would take these
tactics once they're disenfranchised
and it would all boomerang back on us
didn't we have the foresight to know
that if
if if we didn't say anything and let
all these groups play out locally using
insurrectionary tactics and all the way
from i saw skateboard you know
everything
that from the helmets to the gas mask
the skateboard to
to the pedestrian tools i personally
did not see one gun the whole time i was
there and that's significant
because the people on the front
apparently
from photos and it would be interesting
the to find
out how many guns were there but among
the populist crowd
there were people with flak jackets body
armor but there weren't people with
with with arms that i saw so it would
have
have to have been a very small minority
but that all works
under the same that tactic of using
these pedestrian
i saw a woman with coming out with a um
a chair a leg to a desk
like one of these ornate swervy and it
had been pulled off of a desk and she
was and she was
sorry holding it like a weapon and
and so this idea of using makeshift
weaponry from
pedestrian materials that all comes from
the leftist movement
what we saw uh over the summer of
insurrectionist uh
tactics from anarcho-antifa aligned
groups and i do get need to get to the
difference between anarchist and antifa
there's been a lot of talk out there the
antifa groups were not
a part of this because it's
ideologically
opposite of what they were saying black
lives matter dc said
everybody stay at home they said that at
the same time
some affinity groups were
planning uh black black action but
presumably at night
at black at black lives matter plaza
they were preparing for another repeat
of what i was expecting to cover which
uh was november the 14th
and december the 12th when those two
groups clashed at night and started just
larping and beating on each other so
yeah
go on so so those groups stayed those
groups for all i know
they stay at home they they had a couple
of documenters that went
in to take pictures but from what we
could see they did not enter the capitol
they were culturally
just there as a fly on the wall the uh
so yeah
okay there are a couple things going on
here and i have to apologize
to to my audience here
there are so many threads here that it
is very hard
to navigate this story and really paint
it in any disciplined way and i
regard that as a symptom of the fact
that there is a kind of
there is a force that tries to prevent
you from crossing the line it's one
thing
to report on one side or the other but
it's a sin
to report on both it's a sin to try to
figure out
what the the middle ground is where
each side has it wrong what they might
have right
um and so the point is there are very
few people doing
what you're doing there are very few
people doing what i'm doing
the reason there are very few people is
that the pushback that you get
and the pushback even in terms of you
know
having your channels uh de-platformed
and things like this
makes it uh a very hard road to navigate
so what that means is that when somebody
like you
who has seen both sides of this
has been uh in the street has circulated
in
both settings that when you come to the
fore
there are just too many things to say i
have the sense that we could go for 24
hours and really
exhaust all of the the threads that are
here so
yeah anyway i'm not sure exactly what to
do about that
but um yes the tactics
are deliberately
confusing they reside below
a certain threshold so that it is much
harder to tell the story
so in portland for example we had um
the antiva antifa blm anarchists
launching fireworks
at police officers and federal buildings
right fireworks has a kind of a festive
connotation it sounds fun and dramatic
these are explosives are they explosives
designed to do huge amount of damage
they are not are they dangerous yes if
you point them at somebody
so anyway the point is it's very hard to
report what happened you know
the fact that firearms were not uh
at least common amongst those who
stormed the capitals a fascinating fact
right these are almost certain to be
very well armed people
who left their weapons at home while
storming the capital
right yeah i'm not sure exactly what
that says but it certainly says
something
well that that yes there were not guns
everywhere
we've seen the pictures in michigan when
there were and
and one one note this this protest
at the capitol salem oregon you have to
see that that was the uh
canary in the coal mine that you had for
the first time
right-wing riots uh before christmas
uh at the oregon capital uh those
it almost when you look back at that
that video you think oh my gosh that was
just a small
tiny small scale idea
of what this sort of uh feeling was
coming from the right populist crowd
that was you know you had the proud boys
did not show up if they were there
you wouldn't know and and uh their
chairman said we're gonna wear black
and he said that we all thought in
reference to
expected clashes with antifa aligned
activist groups
but no if they were there there were
lots of people that were all in black
and you couldn't tell
who was who and this is something that i
blogged the night of the
the fifth which is how will we know who
is who even on the night
or the night of the fifth when i was at
black lives matter plaza
an anti-covet restriction uh
anti-government overreach types were
you know yelling through the bull horn
and clashing with police trying to get
closer into black lives matter plaza
and there were some clashes uh i was
seeing
we saw proud boys who were in all black
and we also saw some people wearing the
orange beanies
of shut down dc which is the group that
famously showed up it uh was it josh
hawley's residence
uh outside and with a megaphone and uh
so we saw some right rightists or people
on the right
wearing these people were appropriating
left-wing accoutrements and costuming
okay so this takes me back to something
you said a few
minutes ago which i really want to
highlight yeah
the there is
the what you discovered where you have a
blm
activist and a proud boy discovering
that they have a great deal in common
but there are things they disagree over
but actually bonding over the number of
things that ought to unite them
uh is i think the big hidden story here
that in some sense we are fiercely
divided
so that we will not be fiercely united
right and this is this is why i started
the
unity movement this is the exactly the
danger i saw coming out of this election
and the idea is there is a general
sense of frustration at
basically the public being frozen out of
the well-being that is generated by our
system
increasingly systematically frozen out
by a pervasive
culture of corruption much of which is
legal
and so the point is if you have a
legal culture of corruption that causes
the government
to do the bidding of those who can
pay to have their bidding done at the
expense of the public
it will create massive unrest
and distrust and the fact that that
unrest and distrust is divided
into factions that are pointed at each
other rather than there being a broad
recognition
that actually yes americans have a right
to be very angry with what has
become of their governmental structure
and neither blue nor red is the solution
to it
blue and red are the problem and
how we americans address that is a very
difficult
puzzle increasingly this week i see
people
toying with ideas of the right scale
right
new political parties a recognition that
the parties that we have
are simply too compromised to be rescued
that seems to me
uh obvious right but people are now
discussing it
um and so in any case what i want to
point out
is that you're committing a kind of
physical heresy by moving between these
camps and listening to them both
because what you're going to find what
you are finding
what i'm finding by being someone from
what i would say
is the far left not the far left that's
in the street but
i come from a very left perspective and
i talk to all kinds of people on the
right who are not what i was led to
believe they would be
right yeah same so um that discovery
is uh in some sense
the greatest threat to the narrative
engine that wants uh everybody to
stick to one version of events that
tells them exactly who their enemy is
and what danger that enemy poses and
then turns off their processes of reason
so they can't discover
that's not even true right and this um
the events at the capitol play right
into this
but you know in some sense you were
there you're you're the key to
understanding what actually happened
well i saw so many similarities and
i tried to discuss it and of course
maybe it was
too early too soon because bringing this
stuff
up that that i was seeing the similar
tactics a similar strain of populism
and one thing that i said as a riot as a
riot is a riot and it's just the same
stuff i'm seeing under different banners
and people just got furious with me
and i understand that i'm not talking
about
your the moral alliance to causes and
how you interpret them and
i'm talking about the people there what
they were talking about as far as the
constitution
and again it's defining the crowd they
define themselves
united under patriotism so while they
were trashing the capital they weren't
burning it
and there's some other significant
thing there's some significant images
that are being cherry-picked
again this was a five-hour ordeal
in which you had tens of thousands that
were marching in
and breaking police lines that were
completely unprepared for
this level of riot mass riot this was
this was just unlike anything i've ever
seen in my life
[Music]
you